réglons tout de suite la question vous
avez été pistonné pour pour travailler
avec Bertolucci ou escape toujours le
piston toujours dans ce milieu on couche
on épistolet tout ça non oui oui je sais
pas en fait je sais pas j'en sais rien
[Musique]
Louis Garrel bonjour bonjour Est-ce que
vous êtes retourné la Cinémathèque pour
vous préparer à ce rôle non plus quand
j'étais petit avec papa avec papa mais
c'est pas un lieu culte tout dans pour
moi speech pas du tout un cinéphile
j'aime pas parler des films avec les
gens j'avais des fois pour voir des
films en fait qu'on peut pas voir en
salle mais sinon j'allais plutôt avec
son Christine Odéon tout ça
vous n'aimez pas parler des films on va
essayer quand même de parler du vôtre
innocent réglons tout de suite la
question vous avez été pistonné pour
pour travailler avec Bertolucci ou ce
qui est bien sûr toujours le piston
toujours dans ce milieu on couche on
épistolet tout ça non oui oui je sais
pas en fait je sais pas j'en sais rien
me donner le rôle donc j'ai accepté de
le faire quoi mais après les pistons ça
je peux pas savoir en fait c'est
toujours au dessus de soi c'est toujours
Dieu qui a réglé ces histoires là donc
je peux pas savoir
avec une canne faites un type très
fringant de 60 ans qui plaît aux femmes
et qui a un grand dragueur ouais je suis
content avec lui moi je connais pas
toute la période de 1900 je connaissais
surtout le dernier premier temps à Paris
le dernier
Tangoo dernier tango je me retrouve plus
mais c'était son dernier tango dans les
années 70 avec Marlon Brando quand même
bandeau ouais il m'a parlé de ça la
première fois que je l'ai rencontré il
m'a parlé de Brando De Niro Depardieu
alors j'étais pas du tout impressionné
voilà c'était bien comment il vous a
dirigé parce qu'il y a des scènes très
très sensuelles ou vous osez tout sans
on a presque l'impression sans pudeur
c'est c'est entre guillemets bon c'est
la question un peu bateau mais c'est
difficile ça c'est quand on un cinéma
c'est plus concret que ça quoi pour la
scène on doit se mettre lui première
scène où on se met nu voilà bref il y a
les techniciens qui sont gênés les
acteurs sont gênés alors on se dévoile
on se met tout nu puis ça se ça se
dérègle quoi face à ce mets en place
tout seul en fait finalement enfin c'est
pas les scènes de nuit qui sont les plus
compliquées à tourner je le sais pour
avoir fait un autre film là qui est
encore plus compliqué que celui-là à
faire en terme de nudité de scène
durafer que c'est pas celle-là qui sont
plus compliquées ces scènes les plus
simples
[Musique]